et contrairement à la tradition il
représentait sans barbe est normalement
et il a en réalité avec barbe ou sans
barbe
on n'en sait rien c'est contester ma
faim sept ans il représente quand même
saint nicolas qui est surtout le pat
patron des enfants et à chaque saint
nicolas sur tout en lorraine où il est
très connu
les enfants sont fêtés et il s'en
aperçoive en relevant leurs souliers de
sport après le 5 le 6 décembre suivant
qu'ils sont plus ou moins garni si
suivant qu'ils ont été très sages ou pas
saint nicolas est sans doute l'un des
saints les plus souvent représenté dans
l'imagerie religieuse statut vitraux
tableau ou encore peinture sur verre
nous le matérialise avec ou sans bas
patron des lorrains il est aussi des
orfèvres des navigateurs et de la russie
il est également protecteur des
prisonniers mais saint nicolas est avant
tout une amie des enfants et des
écoliers qu'il vient traditionnellement
récompensés pour leur bonne conduite
avec quelques jours d'avancé il est
passé dans les écoles et par bonheur
sans le père fouettard tant redoutée des
enfants
à
en vue on m'écrit mieux qu'il ya pas
longtemps l'on me disant que tous les
enfants des écoles étaient très gentils
stagno à je ne sais pas bon bah le père
prétend m'a dit comme ça que d'habitude
l'année dernière et a le beau coup que
tu es méchant à l'effet moment avec et
écoles alors l'aneti tandis que la
hongrie
une lettre comme quoi qu'il était tout
gentil c'est pourquoi je laissais le
surpoids tard à la maison